all right so we have at least a few
samples now we fit the window in here
and so as you can see starting off we
got 1.89 a significantly better bus rate
not necessarily a better profit rate
1.77 way better bust rate and profit
rate 1.66
again pretty good 1.6 1.9 1.8 1.7 anyway
you can see that probably the best
number ish is about 1.7 I would guess so
I think we'll probably go with 1.7
moving forward and just see how 1.7 does
but anyway this is kind of a way where
we can continue we could have continued
basically doing this over and over and
over and over again we can see at least
though that somewhere between 1.5 and 2
is the best number so with that I'm
gonna conclude this video hopefully that
was helpful for some of you guys this is
really the first time we've used the
Monte Carlo simulator to find us a
number everything else before now has
been using the Monte Carlo simulator to
tell us what you know what what our odds
are nothing more so now we've actually
used it to find a variable and the next
thing though or the next step is to use
it to find multiple variables so not
only the multiplier but also how big of
a you know wager should we make and how
many made wagers should we do
so a lot of other variables definitely
come into play here so anyways that's
going to include this video as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions until next
time